hey you guys it's the movie
retrospective
and we're talking about a stephen king
adaptation
which i feel like a lot of people maybe
don't uh talk about so much when they're
talking about some of your better
stephen king adaptations
but this is for sure like among my
favorite stephen king adaptations yeah
this is a pretty good one i mean yeah
and honestly the more times you see it
i've probably seen this i think i saw
this in the theater when it came out
like back in 2007 and i've seen it
probably three or four times
subsequently
every time you see it you pick up on
more [ __ ]
um
and it's really cool because i mean this
is based on a short story that came out
in 1999 from uh that was in everything's
eventual
and
the short story is really good i
actually really liked it but i like too
the way the movie kind of like builds
out from that story and like because the
short story didn't really have much of a
backstory like for the main character so
they really kind of um you know had this
whole like rich backstory going on and
it also goes a little bit more
i want to say the movie goes in a little
bit more philosophical direction or more
like a um
kind of descent into hell like dante's
inferno kind of direction
whereas this short story i feel like was
slightly maybe a little bit more
hinted toward lovecraftian in the sense
that in the short story like the hotel
room room 1408
was kind of like
hinted that it was sort of
inter-dimensional in some way like there
was some kind of entity
like on the other side of it that was
doing [ __ ] whereas like i said in the
there's a little bit of that in the
movie but i kind of feel like the movie
went more in a
you know the hotel is your own personal
hell you know and you gotta like work
through [ __ ] type of situation you know
what i'm saying it was kind of like that
i've seen this movie actually called the
shining meets jacob's ladder that's what
i was thinking which is actually a
really good uh a really good comparison
if you like the shining where you had
the kind of the story of a damn haunted
hotel with a [ __ ] really bad room in
it what was it called 238 or what was
the the room in it's shiny well in the
movie it was uh wasn't it two three
seven two three seven yeah but i said
that wasn't that in the book though
yeah but i can't it's kind of a
situation where a guy goes to stay in a
hotel room that's like that
it's got a bad
of being haunted he's a paranormal
investigator paranormal writer kind of
like jenny
he's like that and he goes in there and
he thinks it's buck
but it turns out no it's the real [ __ ]
it's pretty good it's pretty cool yeah
the thing about it like i said it's not
really haunted but
i guess no it's like a hell it's like a
poor little hell
right kind of what you'd call it well
yeah because the thing about it and to
be honest like since this movie came out
it did actually really well like when it
came out initially but i feel like it's
developed like even more and more of a
cult following like as it's gone on
because
as i said there's so much the people
have like a lot of different theories
about this
um
and some of that stems from which i
didn't even realize until
recently until i started like
researching this
this movie has
three
or four
alternate endings oh it does now we
watched the version that's on to be at
the moment
that has the theatrical ending because
that's the ending that i remember seeing
when i saw this in the theater however
it also has a director's cut ending and
we'll get into what the differences are
later
it has a director's cut ending and if
you buy the blu-ray
it only has the version with the
director's cut ending and it doesn't
have the theatrical ending on it anymore
um so if you want
it which is weird you'd think they'd put
all the alternate endings on there but
maybe they couldn't for various or i
don't know why they couldn't but i don't
know it seems kind of weird and it seems
like
uh fans are kind of divided over which
ending they like better
now
i've seen the other ending not like
attached to the whole movie like the
director's cut ending not attached to
the whole movie because i've only seen
the theatrical version
and i'm gonna say even though you would
think that i would probably like the
director's cut version ending better
because it's more of a downer and
usually i like that
um and you know the theatrical one is
kind of more of a happier ending
but to be honest thematically i think
the theatrical ending works better
than the director's cut ending so i
don't know i don't get into that a
little bit although i gotta say for dr
sleep now that [ __ ] director's cut is
so much better well it depends i mean
that was a different director i mean
that's a completely different director
in a completely different movie yeah i'm
just saying that however i you know i'm
not saying oh across the board all
directors all directors cuts are
necessarily better than theatrical cuts
sometimes they're not i mean sometimes
the director is
self-indulgent or sometimes their ideas
thematically don't match up with my
ideas thematically like what i took from
it so i do kind of feel like and i'm not
[ __ ] on the director of this who's
uh mikhail hamstrom by the way
but
um you know it's and i don't and i do
like the other ending i just think that
the theatrical ending i think
thematically works better for me just
because of the messaging that it puts
across
uh so i will say that but you know if
you like the director's cut better
that's totally fine too
stephen king movie fans or book fans
i've seen both the theatrical cut and
the and the director's cut of dr sleep
and dr sleep theatrical cut that movie
got panned i liked his okay the
director's cut i'm gonna give a special
plug if you don't have that director's
cutter you don't see the expanded
director's cut on streaming it's a
totally different movie it's a lot
better
so i'm just
just giving a plug to [ __ ] doctor
sleep because that was a good movie if
you saw the right cut
yeah and well i you know that's kind of
true of any movie that has like multiple
endings like i said this one has
at least three endings that i'm aware of
although two of them are kind of similar
um but the theatrical ending was kind of
more the quote-unquote happy ending so
what we have here like i said now
interestingly this started out as a
short story
stephen king started writing it and i
asked if you've read his book his
non-fiction book on writing which i if
you're a writer i'd totally recommend
it's one of the best books about writing
that i've ever read um you know the the
advice and stuff that he gives in there
is like really really helpful
um
he actually started writing this story
like at the end of that book
as an example of okay here's my first
draft of a story like he wrote like the
first however much of it and then he's
like and now this is my first edit and
then he shows what he took out and what
he changed around so he's trying to show
you like what his process of writing is
like
and i guess that he was so kind of like
interesting he's like oh you know what
that's actually a pretty good idea for a
story so he finished it and then i think
he did um he did something called blood
and smoke which was like an audio
narration like an audiobook that he did
and then they published this in print in
1999 and everything's eventual like his
short story compilation
so in the short story
you're pretty much starting right when
the main character is going into
room 1408 this supposedly haunted room
but in the movie obviously they have to
like flesh it out so i will say
i love john cusack in anything i will
watch john cusack in anything he's one
of those actors that
if he's in a movie i'm like [ __ ] it i
don't care if the movie's bad i love
john cusack so i'll watch him in
anything
and for the bulk of this movie like once
he gets into the room
it's pretty much just him
like him in the room like for the second
half of the movie and he
kills it he just knocks it out of the
park i think because this whole movie
like pretty much rests on his shoulders
if he was phoning it in or if he wasn't
good in it then i don't think this movie
would have been as successful as it was
um so so he's great when he's on his own
in the room but i also love the
interactions between him and samuel l
jackson like that whole big scene where
they're setting all it up all of it up
yeah it's just so great like the
interplay between the two of them is
fantastic i was mentioning that it
doesn't matter mention to jenny that was
watching sam jackson watching him
[ __ ] do his thing and he he he always
in a way kind of plays himself you know
what i mean but he plays different
interpretations
but when you see jackson
that's what you want you want to see
samuel jackson do this [ __ ] and i'm
watching him do this role and i'm like
man i cannot believe that he started off
in coming to an america with that damn
shotgun holding up mcdougalls yeah
that's what you first see because he did
a good job with that just psycho [ __ ]
with the shotgun dude's career went a
long way because he's got some [ __ ]
gravitas man never forgot that character
[ __ ] crazy ass crazy-eyed [ __ ]
dude with the [ __ ] jacket and the
[ __ ] shotgun and mcdouals you know
and who would have thought that that
dude would be a superstar yeah you know
well he was so memorable he was
memorable and i guess you know behind
the scenes probably everybody liked him
so he became a legend you know but uh no
he does a great job on this
i like him in this role because it's
very i mean for him it's quite
restrained yeah in this role you remind
me as i said it to jenny the time says
man he reminds me of will reminds me of
will walker yeah
yeah we have a friend named will that
yeah goth black dude that kind of like
it kind of looks like a little bit like
resembles him big old tall yeah very
very tall kind of the same uh facial
structure yeah only a little bit younger
he's a little bit older than me and feel
like and that's that's the way and his
yeah and his the way he carries himself
yes very much just like that um i got a
video to prove it
i'm [ __ ] loaded and [ __ ] will's
next to me talking to the camera and
[ __ ] i can barely stand up he keeps
hitting me on the shoulder waiting for
that video somebody took that out of the
damn phone but that was yeah that was
pretty yeah out front of mannequins but
uh but yeah so uh so what you have uh at
the beginning and like i said i like
the reason this movie i think just stuck
with me and the reason that it's so good
and why i think it's one of the best
stephen king adaptations and it gets
better like every single time i see it
and i keep picking more stuff up in it
because it takes its time to set it up
because it's it takes a while before he
even gets to the room like i said the
short story pretty much starts with him
going to the room and that's because
it's a short story
this one kind of sets up
you know his name's mike enslin
uh he is
i guess he started out as a regular
novelist or a regular writer and
even though that seemed to be like the
way he was doing more stuff that was you
know based on his life and more like
emotional truth and everything like that
and maybe that wasn't working out as
well and so he started writing about
these paranormal things
and i don't know is it i don't know if
it's unclear whether because he's going
through like his daughter
uh katie died of it looked like leukemia
like presumably and after his daughter
died uh him and his wife lily like
drifted apart and so he's dealing with
that and he also
has a thing where he's just angry he's
angry at the world because you know he's
angry at god because he perceives god so
he's become like this bitter atheist
because he's kind of like well why would
a god take you know my daughter away
from me like that and so he's just he's
just really really cranky about the
whole thing so i'm not sure if it was
before or after his daughter died that
he went into this paranormal type of
thing he might have been doing it before
but when you meet him at the beginning
of the book he's still writing these
presumably still successful books even
though it looks like the success of them
is on the decline you know because he
goes to a book signing there's only like
three people there yeah but he writes
these books like you know 10 haunted
hotels and all this other kind of stuff
but he doesn't believe it he's basically
just doing it at this point to help out
the hotels it is yeah it's totally
haunted whatever and he's like he but he
doesn't really believe it so it's almost
kind of like he's defrauding people
because he doesn't believe in ghosts
anymore so i mean i took it as
he was writing that before
but then
i don't know but then like his daughter
died and he's like okay i don't believe
this [ __ ] anymore but i'm still gonna
write it for the money
or
or he started writing it after because
he just went on this cynical
type you know so either way during this
part of the movie man i'm kind of like
going mad dudes in a way kind of like
jenny yeah but
jenny's written a lot of paranormal
stuff but always from a neutral
standpoint she in general does not
believe that it's spirits of the dead
there's other explanations that that are
paranormal also which some of the books
get into that uh but she's seen
paranormal activity it's just that i'm
i'm i'm i agree with her
i've you guys have seen if you've read
um um
looking um math mountain poltergeist if
you read that i i went i lived through
it
it scared the [ __ ] out of me at the time
and it was paranormal but i don't think
it was the spirits of the dead
uh rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis iconic there's a
scientific
there's some scientific theories that
explain that with quantum
quantum entangled particles having to do
with quantum consciousness which is some
heavy duty quantum mechanics where the
mind might be able to alter matter
slightly
or at least your perception of matter
which
what is matter you know they don't know
but that paranormal concept can be
explained in quantum mechanics in
quantum terms sometimes
if it seems to be a
legitimate phenomenon some of it's made
up like mothman is made up
but i kind of feel like in this you know
context of the movie he seems more like
just anything and everything he just
he's very cynical about it like
everything's [ __ ] he's just doing it
for the money and it's almost kind of
like but i kind of feel like in a way
he almost has like a little kernel of
hope left like it's kind of kind of like
houdini kind of burned out where he was
skeptical about it but then he's like he
kept hoping that it would be true
because you know he oh he could talk to
his dead mother again or whatever so i
do kind of feel like there's that little
kernel
of him in there somewhere that he's like
well maybe like there's a possibility
there's an afterlife i can see my
daughter again but the way he presents
at the beginning of the movie is very
cynical very
uh sardonic very sarcastic it's just
he's doing it for the money he like even
like they show which i really like they
show like a little bit of a prologue at
the beginning of him going to a
supposedly haunted hotel and like the
couple that own it like a bed and
breakfast or whatever and they're really
excited that he's there and they're like
oh we gotta tell you about all the
ghosts that are in the thing and all
this other stuff and he's just like yeah
whatever just give me my keys it's like
and he just sits in the room uh and then
he's kind of dictating into his thing uh
yeah five skulls whatever it's just you
know what i mean so he's just like
really over it at this point i don't
think that's the only reason why he's
holding out hope though because he said
some other stuff that made me think that
he did believe that there's a
possibility he said that i've been to
some places where some bad [ __ ] happened
and yeah you could get a real heavy
feeling there the feelings
although he was just saying that to the
lady because that was what he was
expected to say maybe i don't know
because i've been in places like that
bad feelings yeah but what but yeah but
his character
the way his character was at the
beginning was he did not believe in
anything like that but he was just
answering her question
like to make her feel better so it's
like yeah so buy the book for me kind of
my interpretation was that he did have
bad feelings and that he was thinking
that well maybe there's something to it
but maybe not just might have just been
feelings but that's what i was thinking
i was thinking that he did have the
ability to kind of sense it
that's that was my interpretation but
maybe i'm wrong yeah but um so at this
point so i guess since he's still kind
of well known for doing these kind of
like 10 haunted hotels and like i said
he's writing these books to kind of help
out the hotel owners because everyone
will come there if it has a ghost story
attached to it so he gets in the mail
like all of these
flyers and [ __ ] like that from other
hotels so he gets this postcard and this
postcard that he gets which does not
have a return address on it although the
uh the stamp is new york city where the
hotel is uh all it says it's addressed
to him and all it says is don't enter
1408.
and he's pretty um
you know he's pretty intrigued by this
because he's like oh this is new like if
this is a hotel that's wanted me to like
investigate their scary room then this
is like a new like a novel way to go
about it like some kind of mystery so
this kind of intrigues him now as i said
you never find out like who sent this
postcard to him
and
that's another thing that's like a cause
of a lot of different uh theories about
the movie one of the theories being that
samuel l jackson's character olin
who is the manager of the dolphin where
room for 1408 is is actually the devil
um i'm not sure i buy that exactly
my kind of theory is i think that it's
almost kind of like
i don't like not literally but i think
in some ways like john cusack's
character i think he kind of sent that
to himself
or it could have been like samuel l
jackson's character but i don't think
samuel l jackson's the devil though
although i do think that there's a thing
with the hotel room like i said being a
sort of like
not necessarily dissented to hell but
kind of like dante's inferno where you
kind of like go through all the sins of
your life and expunge them and then come
out on the other side better you know
what i'm saying whether that's out into
heaven or out and or whatever i do kind
of feel like it's that but i don't know
who summoned him there necessarily it
might have been like a future version of
him or something so he gets this
postcard
and as i said it's intriguing he points
out oh the numbers 1408 that also adds
up to 13 and he's like oh okay that's
you know that's cool that they went that
far into doing it so then he actually
does go to new york there's a whole big
thing where his publisher is like are
you sure you want to go back to new york
presumably that's where his estranged
wife still lives that's where his
daughter died so it's going to be this
big emotional thing
and he's like no it's just a job it's
fine so he goes back to the hotel now
interestingly when he gets there olin
the manager samuel l jackson just is
really really does not want him to stay
in that room now
john cusack is apparently he's kind of
like yeah yeah i know like the whole
song and dance ooh it's so scary you
don't want me to stay in there liability
yada yada um he thinks it's all part of
the sizzle that they're selling you know
what i mean like this room is so haunted
we can't have anybody staying there but
samuel jackson is like no i'm [ __ ]
serious uh this room is [ __ ] evil he
says
and um you know so john cusack had done
all this research all of these people
died in the room
jumping out the window you know just
slitting their wrists or whatever and
then uh olin's like yeah but did you
hear about all the people that died
quote unquote natural deaths in there
like one dude that drowned in his
chicken soup and [ __ ] like that and uh
he had not heard of that so he's like 56
deaths have happened in this room
nobody lasts more than an hour uh
they're like we do clean it but we leave
the door open and we go in shifts and
there's only in there for like 10
minutes at a time
and so the i really really like like the
setup this is a pretty long like
conversation between the two of them
where they're setting up like all the
[ __ ] that happened in this room i think
it's the best part of the movie actually
it is actually that scene is really good
and like i said i really like that the
movie took the time to set it all up
so then when he gets to the room like
however long in it is like 45 minutes or
whatever um you're kind of like primed
for
the [ __ ] that starts to happen and the
interesting thing about this room and he
even brings this up he's like the room
isn't haunted they're like in the sense
that there's ghosts in it even though a
bunch of people have died in it
basically all samuel l jackson says at
first he's like it's just a [ __ ] evil
room what the room seems to do
kind of like i guess the shining well no
i guess the shining didn't really do
this either but it's kind of like more
along the lines of
it targets the individual that is
staying in the room and essentially
gives you your own
personal descent into hell so it will
it will do things that are uh meaningful
to you specifically
and it seems like it essentially wants
to drive you mad
uh so that you will kill yourself yeah
and that's gonna be different for each
person you're not really going to get an
explanation of how or why that i did if
there is i didn't make it it just is
it's it's some kind of a rift in between
dimensions or it's just some kind of
effect that this
like why is it happening way up high on
a floor inside of a hotel it never
really explains it it's just bad place
yeah and as i mentioned it doesn't have
to because it's almost it's like a
metaphorical yeah journey and honestly
there's a great video i can't remember
uh what it's called but it was like half
an hour long and you'll find it if you
like look for 1408 explained or
something like that and it was it's
several years old but this guy did like
a half an hour
uh examination of 1408 and compared it
with dante's inferno and it's almost
it's not like a one-to-one match-up but
it's very very close all of the stuff
that happens to him in this room like
you know the room getting too hot like
the room getting freezing cold like uh
the the person that comes after him with
the hammer so like that um it all has to
do with
his
sins that he's trying to expunge like
while he's in this room and it all has
to do with like uh you know as you
descend down
the layers and honestly he even says
like when the room goes freezing cold he
even brings up dante's inferno
and is trying to remember what level of
hell this was so it was very deliberate
and honestly if you look at a summary of
inferno and look at a summary of this
movie like every single thing that
happens to him in this it's very very
similar so obviously it was done on
purpose which is why i kind of like
which is why i like the theatrical
ending better
because it's more he went through his
own personal hell
the room didn't
defeat him he actually destroyed the
room
and was willing to sacrifice himself to
do so
but he didn't die he came out of it on
the other side with all of his sins
expunged as a better person so i think
and also he got his faith back because
he when he got out
in the theatrical cut he gets out and
the only thing he saved was his tape
recorder and when he plays the tape
recorder back
uh him and his wife who have gotten back
together
hear their dead daughter's voice on it
so he's basically like oh faith you know
an afterlife exists ghosts exist so he's
gotten his faith back
in the director's cut which like i said
if you buy it on blue right now i
believe at least in the united states uh
the blu-ray the it only has the
director's cut ending on it
that one um john cusack's character
actually dies in the fire he he is
sacrificing himself to destroy the room
so other people don't get [ __ ] over by
it but he dies
and then
um in the one like samuel l jackson like
gets all of his stuff
and he plays the tape and hears the
daughter's voice and then there's like a
jump scare where you see like a burned
looking john cusack in the back of his
car
and then he looks and he sees a little
girl which you presume is katie the dead
daughter and you see john cusack and
they're like walking away across the
cemetery like at john cusack's funeral
which
that's
an okay ending too but
i do kind of feel like that sort of
makes everything that he went through in
that room like the ordeal that he
suffered through it made it like not
mean anything although i guess he did
end up with his daughter in the
afterlife but
i don't know i kind of i'm kind of of
two minds about it you know what i'm
saying
i didn't like like the cheapy jump scare
thing where samuel l jackson looks in
the rear view mirror of his car and
likes then sees like burned john cusack
in the back like as a jump scare because
it seemed just you know that's something
that a lot of horror movies do
uh so i didn't love that as much
um i don't know i'm kind of on the fence
about which one i liked better i think i
like the theatrical cut better good to
be honest with you but
i don't know i think there's another one
too where
i think that um that actually the
publisher comes back
and the book that he wrote where he was
like inside the thing because there's a
thing where um
you know you think that he's out of the
room at some point like you think that
this whole thing happened
after he like got hit in the head with a
surfboard or whatever because they do
put that in there and that's also a
reference to dante's inferno by the way
like waking up on the shore of something
and you kind of being dead so they do
that but for a lo so for a long time you
think he actually got out of the room
um and then he goes back to like live in
his life and it seems like he sorted
everything out but then he goes to the
post office and they start tearing which
is a great scene by the way like they
tear it on the walls and he's still in
the room and he's like flipping out
because obviously he hasn't like worked
through all his [ __ ] yet
but
i mean
so you had never seen this movie before
you had never seen it okay so nothing
about it yeah um so what did you think
about it i liked it you did yeah the
best part i think was the first part
with with sam jackson and everything you
know doing the setup that was my really
my favorite part of it um
you know it was it was good uh
just like it went a little bit out there
with the with with
i knew it was gonna go out there though
but it was nowhere near like as uh as
crazy as like maximum overdrive or
anything like that you know it just it
was good i would probably put this in
there like this could this could exist
in the same universe as dr sleep
you know yeah that's that's how i saw it
the extended cut dr sleep about like
that i did kind of like the way
yeah i mean it does go kind of
like out there like you know the the
room the room falling away falling away
and stuff like that but like i said
hallucinating but he's hallucinating so
you can do anything with that although i
will say that the creepiest [ __ ] in it
to me is the more subtle [ __ ] like i
love the scene where he looks out the
window because he's like looking like
for help because he can't get out and he
sees somebody in the window like in the
building across
the street and he's like waving at them
and stuff and then it turns out that
it's him
and i was just and if you guys like
after we reviewed like roman polanski's
the tenant where if it's kind of a
similar thing happens
that kind of [ __ ] creeps me the [ __ ] out
yeah that creeps me the [ __ ] out this
story here you know if you guys know
the backstory between me and jenny and
some of the stuff that she's written
together you know me and her have
written it together with you know like
math mountain poultry guys i've always
had weird stuff happen to me every
decade something weird would happen
there'd be wet witnesses and [ __ ] do
most of it
this kind of reminds me
of a time the story you know kind of
reminds me of a time when i got out of
the army a friend of mine named eric he
we got out at the same time we moved to
boston together we planned it
and uh we rented a house and uh
it was just a bad house it was
nowhere near as bad as this hotel yeah
cause some crazy [ __ ] happens in this
one
you'd bring uh you'd be dating girls and
bring them over and they were like
scared to walk around the house together
he had to stand outside the damn
bathroom while they were using the
bathroom and said it just was just an
eerie house that
you know gave you bad dreams and uh
seemed to be always something over your
shoulder watching you trying to crush
you this it was just a very oppressive
house
and never really got down to the bottom
of it just uh
you know i've told the story on a live
show you know how how that got resolved
just had to threaten it with uh if you
keep [ __ ] me i'm gonna burn the house
down and that dispelled it
whatever it was it was i don't know if
it was a ghost uh there was no
no
visual phenomenon no objects moved it
was just waves of emotion
that's the only way i can describe it
this is this how this this
that this hotel story kind of reminded
me of that
although i did like that when he first
walks in
he's basically like this is it like it
just looks like regular
and it kind of starts a little bit
subtle like he goes in the in the
bathroom or whatever he has like his
back turned and then when he comes out
there's like chocolates on the pillow
and like somebody fixed the toilet paper
and [ __ ] like that and he's just like
wait was somebody in here like well my
back was turned like for a second so i
really liked that it kind of started
like that and uh another one of my
favorite scenes too is when he's finally
like freaking out and he's just kind of
like okay i really gotta get the [ __ ]
out of this room he can't get out the
door
and so he climbs out the window onto the
ledge and he's gonna go to the next room
like climb in the window next door
and
uh so then he gets out on the ledge and
then he goes like that and then it's
just like all wall with like no windows
i just i really really like that because
see little [ __ ] like that to me is
scarier yeah than like the big because
the i like that um you know i like how
over the top this was at some point
because like i said he does think that
he's hallucinating and because it's
essentially
i don't know not literally but it is
kind of like happening in his mind and
it is personal to him so it's stuff that
would bother him specifically um you
know an ordeal that he has to go through
uh so they can go as crazy as they need
to with it yeah so i do like that there
are a couple of apparitions like you do
see uh you know kind of one of an older
guy that like jumped out the window like
back in 1912 or whatever or he's seen
the past or he's seeing the past in it
yeah so he does see that
um which
you know i guess is not specifically
personal to him but he did read about
those cases so i guess that's kind of
like coming but i mean i like i said i
kind of like the subtle [ __ ] of like you
know the radio coming on with that
carpenter's song and uh you know and
then it counting down like 60 minutes
because you know olin told him nobody
lasts more than an hour in there you
know usually they die or they run out of
their screaming so it's that kind of
thing all these stories about haunted
places and bad places and paranormal
stuff it all comes from stories that
people
have passed down and sometimes the
stories grow you know um and people
horror writers will write a story based
upon something that's out there
these stories go back thousands of years
um in my experience there's something to
them people do have these experiences
uh but just
just but when you see a story like this
it doesn't don't take it literally that
a real experience isn't as dramatic
as these store as these stories they're
very much you know they're made into
movies you know yeah if it's something
in my experience if something actually
does happen to you
it's not it can be pretty damn intense
but it's not as intense as this
yeah because as i said the thing about
this was that it kind of starts out like
a little bit of a haunting type thing
like i said where oh there's chocolates
on the pillows and they weren't here
before so there's that kind of stuff but
as it ramps up
it sort of gets more like i said it gets
more crazy
but
it's also kind of like it had to be
crazy because i think
i mean metaphorically at least it's an
ordeal that he has to go through
and then when he gets to the end it's so
it's it's just like battering him like
emotionally it's like down to nothing so
it has to be really intense and it's
like a really intense experience and
then when he gets through that
you know at the end
basically the the clock resets after all
of the crazy [ __ ] and it says well you
can either live through this same hour
over and over and over again or you can
do what the lady at the front desk calls
the express checkout meaning that they
want him to kill himself however he
takes a third route because he has
worked through the ship yeah so they
have to visually show you in in in a
cinematic form what this guy's going
through eternal internally yeah which
that house we're in was kind of like
that but um not like i said nowhere near
as intense as this
i would say
if
in okay in star wars terminology it
would be like it's a story about a place
that is strong with the dark side
and like the [ __ ] place where luke
has the damn vision of vader you know
and and uh
and [ __ ] empire strikes back there
are places in my experience that are bad
i don't know why
you can't explain it yeah not with
modern science
maybe eventually they will proceed with
quantum particles
some traces of something left behind
i do kind of feel like it's been a while
since i read the short story um i did
read a synopsis of it earlier today and
i was reading something that was like
comparing and contrasting the two as i
mentioned earlier i feel like the short
story
was more suggesting
that the room was almost like
interdimensional almost i want to say
like slightly lovecraftian yeah uh in
the sense that it wasn't really
explained but there was one point in the
story if i remember correctly where the
wall kind of cracked which happens in
the movie too but it's not quite the
same where the wall kind of cracked and
you could just see like a hint of
something like behind there like some
kind of entity of some kind which like i
said very lovecraftian uh whereas i feel
like the movie
rightly so i feel like uh went in a more
as i said in dante's inferno direction
where they're making it much more clear
at least subtextually that
this is something that he's going
through yeah internally like in his head
it's the mind it's kind of that's
manifesting outward because you know the
the room
when it resets you know when the clock
resets after 60 minutes the room looks
normal again even though obviously
there's been cracks and shit's falling
down and he's like torn the [ __ ] up and
it just so it resets itself
you know what i mean so anything's
possible if it's uh messing with your
consciousness i mean we don't we don't
really know what consciousness is or how
to make anything conscious it's
something quantum mechanical it's not
digital or the internet would be
conscious it's it's
it's uh so once you're once you're
dealing in that realm
anything's possible you know so they're
just trying to communicate that the
place was mind warping
which it definitely is yeah so i mean if
you've never seen this movie and you
really like stephen king movies you
really like john cusack you really like
mind [ __ ] kind of movies like i said
shining meets jacob's ladder and i think
it might have been ryan hollinger that
said that and i was like i think that's
probably the best descriptor of this
movie that i've ever heard and
electromagnetism and electromagnetic
fields can [ __ ] up your mind they've
tried to they've tried to weaponize it
with guns to [ __ ] hit on people hit
people's heads and give them brain
damage and make them put them in bad
moods and stuff though
so who's to say that
a place can't be like that maybe some
kind of an electromagnetic field coming
out of the earth you don't know well i
mean it does happen because you know
they they have done experiments where
certain types of electromagnetic fields
or or something like that like do
affect people's brains and bring that
particular frequency
next it may not necessarily be the
physical brain it might be the damn
field of subatomic particles and quantum
particles that are around the brain
that's giving you that sensation of
existence if you can
you can warp those it would have a like
a literally a mind warping effect on
your consciousness
so
movie might be plausible
another thing that a place that made you
kind of feel really bad
another thing that i kind of liked about
this too and this
really went along with like his
character you know him being a cynic and
a skeptic like when he first goes in the
room and it's just kind of like oh it
just looks like a regular room yeah and
then when the little [ __ ] happens like
the chocolate on the thing and the he
immediately thinks he goes to like the
rational thing like you would think oh
somebody snuck in here like behind my
back so he starts looking for a person
and then like as [ __ ] gets crazier and
crazier he still
is trying to find a rational explanation
he's like oh well you know olin gave me
this expensive 800 bottle of whiskey he
must have dosed it he does realistically
so i'm like hallucinating so he's kind
of like trying to rationalize what's
happening to him and he does that for i
mean which you would do yeah and
especially somebody with that character
so i really do like if you've been on
lsd before yeah
i've been dosed
yeah so i like that they addressed that
because he's like oh you know i've been
drinking out of this bottle that this
dude gave me who knows he could have put
something in there um which you know
maybe if that's another interpretation
of the movie maybe he ditches
maybe
or a bad one uh that seems like that
seems like the most boring explanation
but that's also another alternate
explanation for this movie but yeah so
this movie is actually uh at the moment
as of this recording it's you can watch
it for free on 2b but keep in mind that
the ending on the 2b version is the
theatrical version if you buy this on
blu-ray and i'm not sure about if you
watch this on other streaming services
um the blu-ray only has the director's
cut the the bummer ending uh whereas the
theatrical cut is the more hopeful or
positive ending um so keep that in mind
like whichever and like i said there's
another ending too but i've never seen
the other one like with the publisher
getting a book and stuff um but my
interpretation of the movie was that it
was a location that was okay i'm going
to give the star wars terminology it was
a location that was
strong with the dark side you went in
there and you underwent a damn
inquisition or a trial for your soul
that's pretty much yeah and it either
purified you when you came out the other
end or it killed you
that's what it was it was like that's
yeah that's exactly right it was
basically a spiritual crucible yeah
that's exactly what it is that's how i
mean that's like i said also how i
interpreted it that's what i thought it
was um and i think the reason the reason
i like the theatrical cut better is
because
he
you know he comes out of it alive
because he had gotten rid of all he had
expiated his sins he'd gotten rid of the
selfishness
and the ego that had gotten him into
that uh situation in the first place by
being willing to sacrifice himself to
destroy the room so no one else would
have to go through it so you know what i
mean nailed it so he yeah and dismantled
it using the phone because his sorcerer
because his wife was coming they said oh
your wife is here she's coming up and
he's like i have to destroy this room i
don't want her going through this like
coming into this room because it's evil
so the fact that he was willing to
sacrifice himself meant that he
had learned he had expiated all his sins
so he just gets to go on to paradise in
dante's inferno terms so that's kind of
where i got but yeah i like spiritual
crucible that's a really good
phrase for whatever the eastern
philosophy spirituality is not it's not
um intellectualism it's a holistic it's
a it's it's a merger of
mind and body the two different forces
of chi of yin and yang the good and evil
trying to find balance in the line
between the two
so the idea of
swordsmen who are psychics that are
walking in between the line between good
and evil that's all jedi stuff all right
and that's what this is kind of about
too all right um
it's not about
scientific rationality it's about
instinct oh and he's
in feelings and emotion you know
there is some
logic to it but it's not all that it
goes outside that goes into the realm of
the spiritual and wherever pla this
place
was
like i said a spiritual crucible you
went in there and you tore yourself
apart uh basically
to get down to your
core
uh which is kind of like in
zoroastrianism you go to hell to burn
off impurities all right and when you
get out of there
yeah that's essential
yeah that's essentially what's going on
right and the fact that he was able to
resist the room because like i said the
room gives him a choice at the end
saying you can relive the same hour
again forever and ever or you can kill
yourself but he chooses instead to
destroy the room to keep anyone else
from having to go through the same thing
that he went through
which meant that he had had won the won
the contest or beat the room i guess
yeah that in star wars turns out to be
yoda absorbing the cheap ball and go
nope and just dismantle it
[Laughter]
be kind of like in christian terms it
would be
um
exorcism to exercise a
a bad place
to just yeah and like i said the more
times i see this movie which is
fascinating because this came out in
2007 and i kind of feel like 2007 most
of the horror movies that came out
around that time were usually like all
torture porn
so the the fact that like a big
hollywood studio made this
and it's actually kind of i mean you can
watch it as just like a creepy
supernatural haunted you know hotel room
movie too but the fact that it has like
all of these other philosophical kind of
like layers to it um that you kind of
pick up more and more like as you wat
the more times you watch it is kind of
pretty amazing i'm glad that people
uh really seemed to like it at the time
it wasn't one of those movies where i
was like what the [ __ ] is this and then
like later it got it was actually like
very well reviewed at the time and
actually made you know decent money at
the time so
so people did recognize it for being
like a pretty awesome movie at the time
it was but i do feel like the
appreciation for it has grown like as
the years have gone by though too
but yeah so uh if you've seen it let me
know what you think about it let me know
which ending you like better or if you
even knew that it had several different
endings because i actually didn't
realize that until quite recently so uh
yeah that'll do it for this movie
retrospective on 1408 and we'll see you
guys on the next one bye